so if you've been watching our YouTube
channel for a while you're probably
familiar with our giant gun wall our
massive collection of every single
airsoft pistol and rifle Under the Sun
we're kind of obsessed with military
culture but this is all just
make-believe here we're not veterans we
don't have military experience but this
week we're gonna be working with some
guys who done it for real and in very
high-level ways where should being a
commercial for the black rifle coffee
company a company that consists of a
bunch of veterans like Matt Logan Evan
JT people who've served in the Army and
have real combat experience so the big
challenge here is a commercial for their
company something that's supposed to be
in their voice and speak to their
audience which is also comprised of tons
and tons of veterans how do we find that
authenticity and that voice here when we
ourselves don't have the same experience
as they do
[Music]
we're here at the ranch today because
we're looking at locations and we came
here because we're a couple of boys on
the journey see we need to find a road a
pastoral road we need to find a better
and of course a place
[Music]
that's good play long pre-production day
for black rifle coffee cup company
commercial we are in the break room and
we have to make this into a shootable
set and we're gonna be breaking some
furniture we're gonna build them score
them so we can throw people into them
later scoring means prepping a piece of
furniture so that when you use it in a
stunt
it breaks the way that you want it to
break rather than breaking and
unexpected and unintended ways a stunt
isn't being done properly unless you can
control the risk factors if I'm gonna
hit somebody with this stool I need to
control the risk factor by having me
determine where the chair breaks these
are stunt mugs we're prepping them right
now they're very delicate as we treated
with extreme caution or if they will
break very easily first shot of the day
I'm about to go in
that looks really good Sam Gabe what are
you doing got it got it got it got it
Jared's gonna beat me up with a cup slam
me in the face and then throw me on the
floor really excited about this actually
you know it's been a long time that I've
wanted to break the coffee cup on his
head daddy didn't raise no [ __ ] good
that's all that matters
all right let's make it happen all right
and action well they will break
I got a nice little goose egg from that
mug the cuts are no joke that was our
test dummy and now I'm scoring them all
because I want them to break easier it's
all good though and I'm ready to fall
and bleed I don't want people to get
injured trying to like get bonked on you
know wood mat is it tough food but he's
not it's not man he needs to act
throughout this whole piece so I don't
want him to like get bombed up and you
know be sore yeah you got a dope back
wrong with me just giving dudes
compliments about their back if I die or
get stitches from this I'm angry P got
anger buy a shirt in my honor
three two great he gave me a nice pad so
that helped got the shot I'm stoked so
don't say they got those twos I think
it's gonna break easier three two one
action
three-two-one kick
[Music]
each one of these takes costs $200 in
mugs alone so this is what it feels like
now where you're shooting what is
probably one of the most difficult shots
of the day Logan is gonna take a sip out
of his mug it's smashed in the back by
Matt wielding a giant stool it's tough
because when we're rehearsing it it's
really hard to get smacked in the back
with a stool and throw a mug perfectly
up in the air to a point where someone
behind them can catch it
so we're easing it by having someone to
basically be out of frame here allowing
Logan to go down with the first mug
someone just go swinging and comedic Lea
tosses a mug up for Matt to catch
solving all of our mug problems there's
two takes we only have two breakaway
stools guys we came all the way to San
Antonio Texas to see if I could throw
this mug up if I miss right the whole
shoot is canceled
everyone goes home and we never do a
shoot with black
ever again mom's sphaghetti dude would
you takes we're gonna get in one Jake is
your cup of parsley filled yes hell yeah
we're rolling no going back now three
two one
pure chaos okay all the guys are playing
smash right now and if I've learned
anything it's that when they play smash
they pay attention the most out of any
time during the day so I'm gonna go and
tell them about all of our sick new
merchandise that's gonna be available
tomorrow on Black Friday you know our
store corridor that store yo hey Sam hey
what's up man hey guys this is available
tomorrow do you remember the olive drab
one that we did this is a follow-up to
that one there you go Ren Nico I heard
you lost some data that'll never happen
again with that just keep it in there
cliff a little cold you could use a hat
since we got plenty of hats
hey we got that one too that's that
one's always there guess what this is
available starting tomorrow this is our
first edition ever bomber jacket my
expectation is that this will be gone by
cyber monday probably the same thing
with this oh and Chris is a bunch of
other stuff that's in there all of these
items and more are available in the
store right now if we try to make them
the highest quality so that when you
support us by buying our merch man you
get quality just like our videos so head
on over to corridor digital dot store
and
[Music]
day two of the black rifle coffee
company commercial you're having a car
chase with this tank looking of Agape
drug this is the LM TV it's a light
medium tactical vehicle it's a twenty
three thousand pound coffee shop on
wheels built in Texas a fully custom
water tank onboard a generator HD unit
and do about 400 cups of coffee in our
state-of-the-art this year she's been to
Florida she's been all the way up to
Seattle Washington and everywhere in
between so pretty freakin cool I've only
been employed with black rifle for I'd
say 1415 months like these guys are the
hardest-working guys in the world they
just took everything they learned in the
military and applied it to working in
coffee in video production in content
all of that stuff they take what they've
earned and they turn it right back into
the veteran community they donate a
major portion of the proceeds to
charities throughout for 70% veteran
rate of employment here at black rifle
coffee and there's this whole stigma
that veterans are broken and dead the
pts and nobody wants to work with them
and everything like that but the
majority those people are guys that are
like what do I do with my life now the
stories I hear from guys that man I
wanted to kill myself but then I saw
what these guys were doing how they took
their life and made something out of
themselves after the military these guys
showed me that I'm not broken when I
come back and there's something for me
and I think these guys like they really
bring it home what it means to be a
veteran post-war
entrepreneur and just all around good
people it's it's it's amazing to see how
powerful these guys are and how much of
an influence they have on other people
to be better
it's the biggest pile of trash I've ever
driven in my life so Sam and Clint will
walk you guys through each of the setups
that we're gonna need to do the big
truck big truck take those this way make
sounds this is the tiny car for this
tiny rock it goes this way too we want
to drive at the safe distance for that
being said it's like whatever is close
as reasonably possible unless the cars
are like 10 feet apart basically we're
not gonna see both in the same shop I
don't extend it so I can like really
swing it around
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
I didn't get anything there sorry let's
reset on the cul-de-sac for one more run
all right let we're taking up we're
rolling
dude that was awesome 22 over 120
[Music]
this is what we can't do in LA but this
is this is like right here's what got me
into this whole thing in the first place
is leaning out of car at high speeds
getting crazy shots of other cars like
seriously my first filmmaking was like
Gameboy pocket like stop-motion with Hot
Wheels that was Razia looking yeah
awesome acting so we've gotten to day
three here at the black rifle coffee
ranch and everything went really
smoothly outside of a little trouble
from some donkeys but I think that's
because after spending days together on
set with tiny guns - and now with this
production here we've really found we
work well together this is for the gag
okay no that's just for daddy it's
Saturday I like how I'm gonna have to do
a helicopter stunt in a robe that's
gonna be an interesting one to figure
out but I'm ready for it
don't get kids out owners over here
awesome man
I've watched quarters since your guys's
first video I mean he had an executive
protection job and I watched a bunch of
YouTube videos dude five years ago I was
carrying a gun for a living like that's
the honest truth of it and now I'm like
infatuated with your rig of how to shoot
black magic it's gets to hopefully make
a couple people laugh yeah I've been
thinking about this a lot this week
there's this like a little weird thing
in the back of my mind because a lot of
this stuff that we've done over the last
ten years here like all these action
scenes even the movies that like we
watched for inspiration are kinda like
stories about what like you guys did in
real life you try and bring as much
authenticity to like anything you're
doing even if it's fake or like acting
or it's like a fictional setting there's
this little of there's a little fear in
the back of my mind that like are we
posers like these guys reowww dude if
anything might take away and all of that
if you guys are taking a satirical
approach to military content I'd say
most people in the veteran community
have a sense of like McCobb humor and
and you can kind of laugh at everything
that you've gone through it's not posed
at all if anything you're bringing value
and call me to a much needed community
I truly believe art as a whole is an
outlet whatever you internalize and you
compartmentalize to get through certain
issues you kind of have to vent that
creatively to make sense of it gives you
a second chance of being a normal human
again because for so long you can't
really have a motion you know you're on
target you're just like I'm getting shot
at I have to return fire and everything
else doesn't matter than the survival of
me and my friends around me how do we
create opportunity for the veteran
community to succeed in civilian culture
with whatever art that they want to I
think the systemic problem with a lot of
the civilian approach and a narrative
for the veteran community is that we're
all broken individuals that are
pill-popping depressive and guys and
we're just like you guys we just had a
different life trajectory and now we're
back and just doing what we love
that's making people laugh have fun live
life is so short there's no dress
rehearsal we've been here for almost ten
days two productions five full
production days and we're done
we have finished you're gonna party
tonight on last weekend in Texas and
we're gonna make - dope ass videos so
subscribe to Cordura crew that's follow
the journey